watch now how Corporate press
continues to push war here is hack
extraordinaire Joe Scarborough on MSNBC
you look at like for instance Rhonda
status
who actually went on Fox News yesterday
and said that Putin doesn't really pose
a risk to his neighbors and uh it just
it's absolutely painful I water it yeah
yeah I know it's just it's absolutely
painful especially
a guy who wants to take control of a
party that Ronald Reagan once LED and
went to the Brandenburg gate and said Mr
Gorbachev tear down this wall what what
a what a uh
what a way to devolve for a party
Ron DeSantis and other Republicans don't
want this next election or really
anything to be about foreign policy it's
their Achilles heel they don't know
anything about it they don't care the
base they have to deal with
um is actively hostile to any discussion
of foreign policy partly
um you know as it is that Anthony
Biden reflex but partly because the
Republicans have abandoned the the
internationalists the kind of muscular
internationalism that Reagan brought to
the end of the Cold War
um and adopted a kind of sour
no-nothingism about foreign policy and
those are the primary voters and this is
I think why you're seeing the house
being the the house member is somewhat
difficult more difficult than the senate
members because that that's the very
core of the GOP base those are the
primary voters that they have to get
past and those voters don't want to hear
anything about foreign policy or NATO or
Ukraine or zelinski because they watch a
lot of TV they don't know much more else
does that clown understand that he's on
TV in a box with five other
know-nothings um and also this this
dismissiveness to the base if the let's
say let's say it actually issued now
first off uh we had four years of trump
we didn't have wars right we did not
have wars so the idea that they've
abandoned things we had peace through
strength Trump dropped a freaking bomb
in the middle of nowhere remember that
mother of all bombs that he dropped and
then people were like whoa this guy's
kind of nuts let's not test them right
we got I think six peace deals in the
Middle East uh Putin took Georgia under
Bush he took Crimea under Obama he took
nothing under Trump so first off the
idea that Republicans know nothing about
foreign policy is just not true I think
Trump has done an incredible job in
those four years of changing the view of
what foreign policy should be we should
not be nation building we should use our
power judiciously that's number one but
number two the dismissiveness and the
smugness and they can only do that no no
where could they do this better than
MSNBC The smugness of this guy Tom
nickels that these people don't care
about foreign policy you know if a truck
if a if a freaking train blew up and
there were 10 000 gallons of ammonia and
all of this toxic and all my water
and in my air and the fish were dying
and my chickens were dead I don't know
that I'd be like could we get some more
money for Ukraine like these people they
are such elitist awful people and guess
what they want world war three
they really do want it
[Music]
foreign